the next awards are for the writers of
our industry their importance to the
motion picture is best summed up by the
15th century Chinese philosopher Ling
Tang who wrote in the year fourteen
sixty three that movies are for the
birds at the end got the words you are
enough out there ain't it yeah
to present the Writing Awards here as an
actor who also reads mr. Kirk Douglas
nominated for the Best Motion Picture
story are the following
Burnley jr. for the metro-goldwyn-mayer
film above and beyond Alec couple for
the captain's paradise British London
films low foot films United Artists ray
Ashley Morris angle and Ruth Orkin four
little fugitive little fugitive
production company Joseph Burstein and
Ian McLellan hunter for the paramount
picture Roman Holiday the envelope and
the winner is Ian McLellan hunter for
Roman Holiday
this is accepted in behalf of Ian
McLellan hunter nominees with the best
screenplay are the cruel see British a J
Arthur rank presentation Ealing Studios
Universal International screenplay by
Erich Ambler From Here to Eternity
Columbia screenplay by Daniel taradash
Lily metro-goldwyn-mayer screenplay by
Helen Deutsch Roman Holiday Paramount
screenplay by Ian McLellan hunter and
John Dighton Shane Paramount screenplay
by a B Guthrie jr. and the winner please
the Spree the screenplay Oscar goes to
Daniel taradash from From Here to
Eternity
seem to have a trend I wish to express
my great gratitude to the firm of :
Adler cinnamon and Jones nominees for
the best story and screenplay are the
bandwagon metro-goldwyn-mayer by Betty
Comden a Nadder of green the Desert Rats
20th Century Fox by Richard Murphy the
naked spur metro-goldwyn-mayer by Sam
Rolfe and Harold Jack Bloom take the
high ground metro-goldwyn-mayer by
Millard Kaufman and Titanic 20th Century
Fox by Charles Brackett
Walter rice and Richard Breen at the
envelope feed the winner is
Charles Brackett Walter rice and Richard
green for Titanic